好 應該都能看到所以首先我開始之前先感謝一下MM邀請我來參與這樣的一個活動我覺得這樣的活動其實對於所有做技術的人來講或者說對互聯網感興趣的人來講都是挺有幫助的然後我這第一場我想講的東西其實是為我自己的一些
经历的总结吧主要讲的是如何通过建立一套合理的流程来提高这个转队的项目质量呃那个首先先声明哈我讲的内容跟Google没什么关系所以大家见谅好呃我先再自我介绍一下因为前面呃稍微介绍过然后我的id呢叫老驴然后我其实就这个普通的哪然后呢我除了
就是平时工作之外呢周末的时候也会做一些呃老司机周报的编辑的工作然后呃就其实对于我觉得对于很多人来讲呃就其实平常的工作其实已经有了很多的技术界点那周末的时候呢如果说有时间去看一些其他的东西也是一个呃不错的就是拓展一下自己的真实面哈好那我们就直接开始呃就我今天想讲的内容呢主要是
如何通過建立一套合理的流程來提升項目質量或者說代碼質量因為我覺得在這點上尤其是過去十幾年我覺得互量處於高速發展期所以很多公司其實都是比較粗暴的那種發展模式所以它可能並不是很在乎流程的建議可能就是產品人上線能跑起來能拉倒用戶就可以了可能
就是沒有那麼在意整套流程的點我個人會把這個工程項目的流程分為下面這四個主要的步驟因為通過這四個主要的步驟來每一步如果都做到位的話我覺得就會比較能做到比較好的質量第一部分就是在動手開始做的東西之前一定要先想清楚整個的流程那這個部分就是傳統意義上講的
軟件設計或者系統設計就是design我覺得很多項目可能尤其在國內的一些一些廠還有一些小廠可能大家都沒有想清楚自己要做的東西是什麼也沒有想到整個流程就直接開始做直接開始動手那就會導致你在動手做的過程當中才會發現有些問題那可能就已經太晚了第二部分就是你做完了那個design之後呢一定要有這個design review
就是需要你团队里的其他人或者说乃至是其他团队的人来帮你看一遍整个东西然后能够覆盖掉一些你自己可能有的一些思维陷阱一些其他的问题你自己发现不了的问题第三部分就是代码审核就是你在做实际实现的时候一定推荐大家一定要做code review这个部分主要是
不管你QA做得再怎么好你自己代码里的问题能够早期就发现早期就弄掉那我觉得这个是最好的选择了最后一步就是在上线之前一定最好团队里面有人来做上线生合因为如果说最后没有一道把关比如说他对产品的Matrix产生了非常大的影响但最后却没有发现问题那我觉得对于这个项目来讲对于business上也不是特别有利好
那么偏讲设计啊设计呢这里主要讲的就是软件设计或者信号设计我是觉得在做设计之前应该考虑一下就是你做这样的软件设计应该应该你为的目的是做什么就是你做这个设计的目的是什么然后第二个呢是你该怎么做这样的设计第三个问题呢我觉得是为什么但是这个为什么有些时候应该放到第一个去做为什么呢因为就是
這個為什麼其實很大程度上指的是比如說你為什麼要做這個項目可能是你需要去跟你們團隊的PM或者說是跟你老闆去溝通的每個過程那如果你能更好的更清楚的了解了這個為什麼做這個東西為什麼你在做這個項目做這個功能也好做這個feature也好那這樣你會對整體的邏輯會有更清晰的認識然後呢最後這個我覺得
那是非常重要但是很多人會漏掉就是有沒有其他的選項可以做不一定要這麼做就是最好是能裸裂一下所有的可選項這點我覺得是比較容易漏掉的因為大部分的我覺得對於馬龍也好就是思維說當中容易調到自己的一個定式裡面去就想說我這樣做就一定是可以的但實際上並不一定說你的想法就是最好的所以最好是能把所有的可選項都裸裂一下
然后最后再比较一下优劣最后再选出一个我是把这个设计的主要就是归纳了一下其实它就是审视一下整体的需求然后你要明确一下你自己的目标然后有一些需求其实是很抽象的尤其是来自于产品来自于跑板或者来自于上面的
商业那边的需求那都是很抽象的你需要把它具象化比如说这个按钮做的什么功能这样然后最后一个我觉得是很多人比较缺失的部分就是文字化你的想法就是你原来的所有想法如果只是停留在脑海里没有把它写下来那这个东西也就是你的想法而已你只有把它落实到了笔头上那才能够去和别人去做交流
我提供一下我自己平时用的这个模板我自己用的模板是用这样的流程来做的第一个呢第一个部分我会先放一小段然后介绍一下项目的背景这个主要是因为看你文档的人并不一定就看你写的那个设计的人并不一定了解你的项目所以呢有这么一个简介背景能让他快速的了解一下整体
第二个呢我是建议大家直接就把你要设计的整个构价也好整个流程就是你的设计的这个软件的流程直接放上来那这个流程图呢就能给大家一个看这个文档的人一个很好的一个预览整体的概览就直接让大家知道说你要做的是什么嗯这个我非常推荐直接放到第二个上面去因为很多人可能看你文档的时候也没有也不是很有耐心你如果说直接把这个东西给放出来呢那我觉得
對於很多人來講可能撇一眼大致就知道你在想講什麼那最後才是把那個新國家設計給放具體的東西給放進來如果講到具體的東西呢我這裡提供一下我自己的有些時候用的這個模板第一個部分呢我覺得是要可以寫一些實現的細節第二部分呢是要講一講這個dataflow也就是你的數據在你的整個設計上比如說你的App裡
这个数据是怎么流动的那第三个部分如果是后端的话会有一些物理构建那如果是做app的话那基本上就是一些比如说Else Matrix就是那些比如说延迟啊耗电啊就类似于这些东西对于你你你增加的部分对于整体的影响然后第四个部分呢就是deployment那就是如果是后端的话那就是不输到这个出中心了那如果是
做app开发就是上线在app store或者是play store之类的然后第五第六部分我觉得是可选的嗯就是第一个呢是开发环境那就如果说你有其他人也要一起做这个东西的话这个开发环境到底你到底要需要点什么那你可以罗列一下介绍一下给别人能够快速的上手嗯最后一个服务级别服务级别协议呢主要是
有一些大厂那会有那些on call或者说有一些其他人来帮你比如说一旦遇到紧急情况帮你来处理事情那它会有一个有一个协议比如说是几个几分钟之内要有响应那如果说你你的改动牵着到了这个部分的话也最好在你的设计当中提一下我觉得这个原则就是原则就是紧早分享就是分享是非常重要的
我建议每个团队都可以建立一下自己的一个模板因为这个模板不一定是要一个多么 fancy 的一个模板多么好看的一个模板不重要关键就是要大家有一个模板可以就去都有一个统一的格式然后要尽早把文档分享出去就很多人会觉得哎呀我这个文档还没写完那可能是不是要等都把它打磨好了我再分享出去我觉得恰恰相反就应该是在你大致已经把整个
整个框架都写完了之后你就分享出去让别人来给你进攻反馈意见因为即便你把他打磨得很好你再分享出去别人还是会有很多的其他的反馈你还是需要做修改我觉得就没有必要等那最后一个就是团队的反馈非常重要这个反馈不只是这个团队不只是你的同事同样写太马的这些同事更重要的是PMUX或者说是其他相关的组
比如说你的依赖族或者你依赖的那些团队的反馈我觉得非常重要之后这个呢是我还是推荐大家如果没有使用在线文档的话一定要要用在线文档用起来我个人认为在线文档哈对我来说是工作效率对你提升最大的东西没有之一原因就是他解决掉了原来你不用在线文档的时候那些互相沟通的那些成本都被解决掉了
那如果说比如说这个设计文档你在一开始的时候就是用在线文档的形式来做那你的沟通比如说你去分享或者说别人给你在上面添加一些注释啊提一些意见什么你都能很快的做回应然后很快的修正我觉得这个这这些在线文档都是能够提升很好的提升这个实际的实际的开发效率啊不管哪个在线文档都可以我觉得因为
基本上所有的三项文档都有那些技术功能那只要有技术功能就够了好那第一个部分讲完了第二部分就是设计审核就是你做完设计之后一定要有一个设计审核设计审核指的就是别人来帮你别让他给你看一看然后提意见然后发现问题如果有不同意见的一定要提出来在这个就咱就一定要把不同意见提出来设计审核我觉得也是
全体条件就是一定要广泛的参与PMUX或者说其他的依赖的项目或者依赖你的项目比如说依赖的后端依赖的接口或者说依赖你的其他的功能的组那也应该来参与我觉得这个就没有必要说一定要圈死在自己的小圈子里这个这个就是尽可能广的来参与大家谁有兴趣都来参与那还有第二点就是我觉得PPT
不是必须的一个必须项哈因为很多时候我觉得大家太关注于PPT了尤其是有现在有些大厂就非要做PPT不可我觉得这个大可不必那个PPT首先他很费时间哈做一个PPT真的太费时间了第二个呢其实也对沟通来讲没有提升太大的效率呃如果说你的那个设计文档按之前那样的流程写下来不是有那个流程图之后不需要PPT直接按那个去讲我觉得也可以讲非常的好
我也是建议那大团一个大团队可以设计统一的比如说一周一次一个时间就是一次一个钟头那先在那个日历上设这么一个会议但是呢具体谁讲呢可以建一个战线文档然后谁有这个需求呢就去feel一下那个战线文档然后就说我这周我想要讲什么然后呢这样就可以建立一个合理的流程吧就每周都会有这么一个分享类似于这样做设计审核的一个时间
有任何問題可以及時的解決我還有一點要強調就是如果是做設計審核一定要有一個產出不能就開任何的會我覺得最開始就應該設定一個目標不能最後是不了了之的那樣的會我覺得就是很浪費時間沒有任何意義了這裡舉了幾個例子就常見的產出可以是比如說產品需求文檔那就俗稱的PRD了那這種主要是在比如說
PM在尋求大團隊來做認可的時候那這個時候可以的產出就是PRD那也可以是比如說比較早期的設計概念然後這個時候團隊來看一看是不是符合現在的大家的這個想法那這個時候產出就應該是一個被批准的一個設計概念然後第三個這種就比較常見的這個是最常見的就是前面如果你做完了設計然後這個時候你就應該得到一個最終版本的設計文道
那这个呢应该大家都是认可的就没有什么太大的意见可以有小的反馈意见但是整体的逻辑设计应该不应该有太大意见那就可以那最后一个呢如果说你们是在订ok啊或者订其他的目标的时候那也可以是ok啊文档或者是ok啊的一些列表那最好是有设置一些mouse动画这样的话你可以在过程当中可以做一些delivery好嗯接下去呃
接下去一步我觉得就是比较重要的是代码审核代码审核其实就是在我觉得很多现在公司也也会有做这样的实践它其实就是它其实就是一个很常见的一个让别人来帮你发现问题的一个过程作用就是帮你发现一些你其中代码里的一些问题然后我觉得还有一些作用还有就是比如说它能避开一些作为陷阱
我举个自己的例子我前段时间我在自己写在马的过程当中我就调到了我自己的一个所谓限定里面去我在做那个举证惩罚的时候我无论如何都没有想清楚就是那个顺序的问题然后最后也是在做那个code review的时候我同时帮我发现然后就算发现了我还是调在了那个所谓限定所以我们最后还是靠开会吧就是开那个
就是在线下就是沟通了15-20分钟我最后才能跳出我那个思维陷阱所以很多时候这种思维陷阱就自己是比较难跳出来的所以需要别人帮助你跳出来然后呢他呢也就是代码审核呢也可以让同事来了解你的工作啊因为我觉得独代码其实是让别人来了解你工作的最佳方式了最后一步呢就是
统一的最后一个功能就是统一的这个代码风格啊因为我觉得很多公司现在追求统一代码风格但最后却落实不下去原因就是没有人来做就没有人最后来做一个把关比如说你写了你就提交上去你就肯定上去不会上去了那最后其实那还是写的无垮八门没有最后一个统一的风格那如果有做代码省后我觉得就会相对会比较好一些
我會把代碼審核分成兩個部分第一個叫可讀性審核那這個呢就是比如說它不一定是指的是你代碼裡的邏輯的問題它是更主要的是那個代碼分隔上的一些問題你追求的是一些代碼的分隔的一致性它不應該是局限於你們這個小團隊的它是比如說整個公司都可以統一的做就都寫這個代碼的人就這個語言的人呢可以來統一的做一個可讀性審核就比如說你都寫OC的或者都寫swift
那可以建立一个可读性设和的一个流程给这个写swift的代码那第二部分就是逻辑审核就是这个部分就需要你熟悉你工作人来做了因为他需要参加过之前的那个design review也要了解你现在做的事情到底是什么这样才能发现一些逻辑上的漏洞接下去就是最后一个了我快点讲那因为时间不太多
最後一個就是上線審核那其實就是來檢查一下你之前做的實驗的時候就是個符合預期那最好能夠附上完整的這個計劃就上線比如說你在哪天上線到哪個地步然後呢然後呢最後呢是要智慧相關的依賴就是你要做這樣的改動那你要上線這樣的產這個功能會不會對對其他人產生影響
我的建议是如果是最后的商业场合一定要通过电子邮件或者参加文档的形式千万不要去开会来做这件事情开会是没有任何效果的因为它需要落实到纸面上这样别人才可以通过一些链接然后去看一些数据或者一些图片来看一些数据我说光是开会其实浮于表面其实很多东西很难以落实
这就是上一层一些常见的里面的一些东西该有的一些东西我就不具体讲了因为时间好像有限上面这些基本上就是我想讲的一个大致流程那里面有一点我没有讲我想顺便讲一下的是上面这些东西其实都比较依赖于沟通尤其是你跟其他组的沟通或者你跟你老板的沟通那这里面就牵扯到一个如何去沟通的问题
我個人推薦一下這本書我不知道有多少人讀過它也是有英文版然後這個是中文版我記得在京東上有版它主要是講的內容是怎麼樣去做一個高效的溝通尤其是在一些比較重要的比較嚴肅的東西上我舉個例子比如說前面我看直播間有人講到那個
前面前面讲到那个有人提到那个比如说你有一个CR然后别人给你提了很多奇奇怪怪的意见搞得你很不爽就比如你就觉得他在搞你他不想让你提交这个代码那这个时候你需要去找他做沟通那这个时候呢我觉得建议你在沟通之前应该要先想好你的主要目标和次要目标是什么在那种情况下主要目标是你要把那个代码给提交上去次要目标是你很不爽
所以你想发现一下的情绪好那你的主要目标既然是要提交代码这个时候你只要一直秉持这个理念任何的沟通任何的对话的作用最后能达成的效果都是能提交代码都可以的情况下那我觉得你这个时候你的沟通可能他在给你做一些反馈的时候你看待那些反馈的这个这个态度就会发生一些变化就会不太一样所以呢其实这里面我讲了这个其实只是一个很小的例子
如果大家有興趣的話建議去讀一下這本書我覺得這本書還是挺有意思的然後也很大程度上對我後面溝通的這個這個這個邏輯產生的一些變化我現在遇到這些事情的時候我基本上就就相對我覺得不太會上不太會就走心吧也不是不走心就是說不太會讓自己生氣或者怎麼了因為其實我覺得這個也蠻常見的一些情況好那我們就推薦一下這本書好
接下去上面的一些就是我今天想非常内容因为今天前面时间单个所以就尽快的讲完那接下去就是问答环节好我现在就把时间交换给MM